The Poetry of is arguably all concerned
with the Sufi path and longing for God
it's a poetry of remembrance of vicar
that Central aspect and practice of
Sufism while all of his work is revered
he is arguably most famous for two poems
in particular one of which is known as
alhamria or the wine ode in this shorter
poem he uses the imagery of wine and
intoxication to express the Divine love
that extinguishes the South the wine
represents love that all-encompassing
love that overwhelms the soul and
intoxication or drunkenness is the
ecstatic mystical state that results
from that love
in memory of the Beloved we drank a wine
we were drunk with it before creation of
the vine the poem Delights in the
transformative power of this wine the
presence of the divine within the
universe and how this Divine is recalled
and remembered through thicker to reach
Oneness